production-wise who's on the new album
because you've we've seen you in the
studio with the who's who I want to say
you were in Madre and we didn't we
haven't heard what that sounds like yeah
we have it I mean so says that's like
the same story for like a million other
artists yeah everyone's like yo I was in
with Dre I'm like can we hear the music
hey I'm happy with my flick I'm happy
with it you got my flick my mom got that
[__] framed in the car she should but
who's who's got beats on the album
um f and Z not sure if you ever heard of
them they're super cold
um ATL Jacob
um
my boy Ellie holler he's super tight
who else I can't think are you doing any
production oh Bongo Bongo super hard
T-minus T minus
um nice little lineup yeah cool little
you know Avengers Squad what do we got
to do to get you in the studio with The
Alchemist oh I did [__] with Alchemist
we did I'm trying to Yo me and Alchemist
will make a fire ass collab you can't do
a whole album yeah I'm down for that all
the way is that like because you're on a
you're on Atlantic Records yeah so like
it's probably a little bit more
difficult for you to be like I want to
do a [__] album with The Alchemist
because now because I'll just pay it
myself
um
that's fair not that he'll even I don't
even know what that'll be because my
argument I pay for the Beats what do you
I would love for you to do like a fool
even if it's not The Alchemist just like
one producer nah for sure I'm definitely
like that's one of my goals this year to
drop a couple of those like one from
Alchemist one with this artist but
Alchemist definitely at like besides The
Alchemist house with just me and that
producer
Metro would be super tight I don't
really I never met this [__] though
yeah it's so good yeah so great that
Thug First free slime free thug I love
the transition he said every time we
make it rain it's a thunderstorm crazy
yo the transition from that record into
the future interlude afterwards yeah I'm
freaking I'm geeking that's just that's
that's that's not messing I listen to
that out more than any album Metro is a
culture curator he's amazing he's
awesome he's I think he's like I I was
thinking about this the other day right
because if we think about like I think
his new album is probably and this might
be recency biased but it feels like the
best hip-hop compilation I'm glad you
recency biased is the real thing it is
but I'm like when I'm listening to this
new Metro booming album I'm like I'm not
sure anyone has really ever done a
better compilation like khaled's never
made an album better than that are we
going down the line whoever's got
compilation albums you know what I'm
saying I just feel like this Metro boom
and I'm he purposely like built it
around this cast of guys now he did that
he took Drake off of one one of the
songs who takes Jake off he did it for
the art it's [__] crazy yes we got to
get you a Metro Boomin in no that'd be
crazy